So this is the situation we have for dispatch. This is what we're
broadcasting this cycle. This is what we have in our reservation stations. And
the question is why hasn't this instruction here in,
RS3 dispatched before this? Because, obviously, it's not waiting for
anything at this point. So the question is, if this is a beginning of a cycle,
then why hasn't this already executed before we got to this cycle?
The first choice is, it was issued in the previous cycle. So basically,
this says that this instruction was inserted here in the previous cycle, so
that's why it didn't dispatch yet. The next answer is, another instruction was
dispatched to the add unit, so this one couldn't. And the third answer is
that if the instruction in RS2 is older than the instruction in RS3,
it comes before it in program order, than RS3 cannot dispatch until RS2 does, so
simple, this instruction cannot dispatch because it's waiting for something.
In this quiz, you need to, select all answers that would possibly be correct.